joining us now is Graham Smith Chief
exec of Republic he was arrested over
the weekend before being released hi
Graeme good to see you thanks for
joining us
um good morning why were you arrested
that was very good question I mean uh we
we're not doing anything wrong we were
going about our lawful business which
they were well aware of and they simply
descended on us uh detained us and then
arrested US and kept us for 16 hours
they had said it was to do uh it was a
um
the original arrest was to do with being
equipped to lock on which we were not
they then changed their minds and
decided there was some kind of
conspiracy to
um cause a public disturbance whatever
the the phrases but I mean they they
were very
um very confused about exactly what they
were doing and why and it certainly
appeared and you can see in the footage
uh how many offices there were there
it's only appeared to be a premeditated
decision to arrest us and disrupt our
protest
you in turn wanted to disrupt the
coronation didn't he no not at all and
this is the point is that we have had
four months of discussions with the
Metropolitan Police I have met a silver
Commander a superintendent on two
occasions face to face with his
colleagues we were very clear about our
plans right down to what equipment we
would have how many placards we would
have roughly how many people were
expecting to be there we gave them a map
of where we were going to be and we had
a dedicated liaison officer we said that
we would be using amplification for
making speeches there would be
megaphones they'll be chanting and that
we would engage positively with people
around us who were there to spectate and
they said repeatedly right up until
Friday last week that they had
absolutely no concerns whatsoever with
our plans
um and that they would engage with us
and ensure that everybody could have a
successful day and the uh
according to the Reuters news agency
three Republican protesters were
arrested for carrying paint what were
you going to do with it
I am not aware of that that certainly
wasn't uh any of the people
um in our team we had eight people
arrested six uh where the van wasn't two
on the mount none of them were carrying
paint so I have no idea uh where that
report comes from
um we were only carrying placards and
other equipment that they were well
aware of
um and we told them when they approached
us on Saturday morning that uh we had
these conversations I told them the name
of the superintendent that I met the
officer assembly wasn't interested
what did you want to achieve what did
you want to achieve
not sure what's going on there you go
you're back again what did you want to
achieve Graham well I mean it's
approaches we wanted to make it very
very clear
that we had
um the the this was not representative
of the whole country that there was a
clear opposition uh this was a
celebration of two
2150 million pounds
uh celebration of a institution that we
oppose
um and it was in that sense a political
event and we wanted to make sure the the
opposition had a very clear voice
um and that voice was significantly
disrupted and of course the voices of
those arrested was completely removed um
and we were not able to do that this was
a peaceful lawful protest sure how did
you know it was 250 million quid
that's been the um estimate put out in
the media so you wouldn't know no no
Graham come on only one newspaper said
250 million and they've since rode back
on it so let's say we can argue about
the details no no sorry let's do the
fact should we I'm giving you the
opportunity to give the facts so don't
don't just give me wild speculation
about numbers
well speculation I've done a lot of
research into it there is no way it's
250 million quid at this stage it's very
easy 250 minutes please
you know you've had someone else early
on uh stating while speculation
suggestions
or not
I will do but you had someone earlier
suggesting that there was Intelligence
supporting the arrests there was no
intelligence
don't tell me or don't but do you want
to have a sensible conversation listen
to what I'm saying I want you to tell me
about the officers coming around to your
house and apologizing that's your
opportunity to say how right you were
that's exactly what I'm doing you had
someone saying that there was
Intelligence uh there was no
intelligence there could not possibly be
any intelligence there was no evidence
of any intent or capacity to commit any
offense and yes the officers came around
to hand back my phone
um and uh hand back the straps that we
had with us which were not uh capable of
locking on but you know there is no uh
suggestion of any uh wrongdoing by the
eight people uh from a public who were
arrested at all there was no intent
there was no evidence of any intent
there was no evidence of any equipment
being carried that would have caused a
crime and we were very clear uh with the
police for four months uh
uh detailed the details of our plans and
they were very clear to us we're almost
out of time what you're going to do next
well we're taking advice from our
lawyers um in terms of what how to
respond to the Metropolitan Police and
as soon as we have an opportunity we
will continue to protest uh where the
king is and against the monarchy because
this is something which uh we have to
carry on doing
um and we certainly do object very
strongly to uh what we do believe quite
legitimately is a quarter of a billion
pounds being wasted on a political
vanity parade and it may have been 100
million pounds it may have been 200
million pounds or 150 million pounds but
when we're in the middle of a cost of
living crisis to have Charles throw that
money away for a pointless coronation is
an absolute disgrace and also I'd say
that Charles has made not one comment in
defense of people's Liberties so we will
certainly be appointing that out as well
and indeed you just did thanks for
joining us on the program